grieving aah before we heard those very
funny lines a moment ago I which issued
from the actors mouth laboriously formed
in the brightest minds and those who act
are enthralled to those who write and I
am just pleased to be here tonight to
present the screenwriting awards and
there are two categories first the
screenplay written directly for the
screen and the nominees are Woody Allen
and that was grass four bullets over
Broadway Richard Curtis for weddings in
the funeral
Francis Walsh and heater Jackson for
having me creatures Quentin Tarantino
and Roger Avery for pulp fiction Vista
peers of its and Christoph des Lasky or
read and the Oscar goes to
grunting Tarantino Roger Avery
ah thanks uh this has been a very
strange year I can definitely say that
um you know what I was trying to think I
think this probably the only award I'm
going to win here tonight so I was
trying to think maybe I should just say
a whole lot of stuff right here right
now I just get it all on my system
that's thought about all year long
everything bullying up and everything
just blow it all just tonight justjust
say everything but I'm not Thanks
I want to thank my beautiful white wife
Gretchen who I love more than anything
in the world and I really have to take a
pee right now so I'm going to go thank
you
you